it was pretty hard to get people to join
infinite a lot of people like oh it's
like too hard like I don't know how to
do that and I think for me I study human
centered design so I started being
really methodical and using a lot of
those design practices that I learned in
class so doing researchers like doing
some research like what could be like
the pain points as we say in design is
it a problem of representation people
don't see people like them doing that
work is that other problems like do they
be doing any more mentorship with an
infinite to help people get these
projects do
like what drew me to collaborate in
theater is that you kind of have no
choice so I'm interested in why you
chose to collaborate in the visual arts
which a lot of people think is a very
like individualistic medium so we're
twins and ever since we were little we
both always collaborated on various art
projects and it was always something
where we felt as though if we work
together on our project we would be able
to accomplish a lot more in in less time
and also the ideas that we would create
if we collaborate and jump ideas between
each other it would just be better or
more innovative or something more
creative than if only one of us worked
on it so then when we when we came to
MIT we really looked for an art
community to kind of replicate that
experience
but when I started actually working on
my project I realized that it's not mine
and when I tell somebody about my
project then it becomes our project like
I auditioned for a Mersenne I auditioned
for vocal jazz ensemble and like I would
say like a lot of my best friends are
people that I met doing music stuff
well if you find that one goal that one
passion that unites people around it and
you allow freedom of collaboration
freedom of speech basically freedom of
merging and moldings different things
together I think that is super beautiful